now the deadly consequences of the
defund dismantle police agenda is
perhaps most apparent in the city of
portland where shootings homicides
they're still rising police morale is
falling amid
never-ending attacks abuse of the police
anti-police rhetoric
from left-wing radicals and elected
officials and the portland police
association leader
he says morale among officers is as bad
as it's ever been
after all 50 riot squad members resigned
after an officer
was indicted for allegedly assaulting a
photographer
here to explain more is the portland
rapid response team commander jacob
clark
jacob i i'll be honest i every cop i
know
wanted to be a cop since they're a kid
so it's not it's a calling for most
people that go into that
your profession to have to leave it
because
things have gotten so dramatically
difficult for you
is sad to me what happened here
oh yes totally agree with you it is
something that most of us
have wanted to do our whole lives just
to clarify that the team didn't leave
the policing profession they just
resigned from
that team so they they still have their
normal jobs
the ryan squad they were they resigned
from that
exactly yeah and this is just
it keeps being i know the timing came
after the indictment of one of the team
members
but really this was a long time coming
the team wanted to quit back in the fall
they met with the
chiefs of police they expressed all of
their issues
um the chief said that they would
address it and um
the team believed that they kept doing
their job
and then really this this indictment of
one of our officers was really
kind of this second to last straw
that broke the camel's back for the team
um you know
i mean but look at that we have go ahead
we have now defund
we have dismantle then we have no bail
laws like in new york and then
cops are getting hit with rocks and
bottles and bricks and molotov cocktails
and if they fight back then they're the
ones in trouble
and now they want cops to hire their own
lawyers to me that that's the end of all
policing as we know it am i wrong
it's certainly not going in the right
direction in my opinion
i mean is it how do you do your job
right
well that's that's the big question i
mean we we just need
like the team just needs guidance they
need support um
and they're we're just not seeing that
and that's
that's what leads to this they they
don't know what they can do
um because the policies are the
interpretations of policies are always
changing
there's new interpretations of the law
that applies to this stuff
it's nobody can tell us what we can
and cannot or should or should not do
and the chaos
riot and how are you operating that
well thank you for telling us your story
i'll tell you this
who are you going to call when when all
hell breaks loose who will you call
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else